[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois philippe chevrier
françois avril tous deux sont devenues
célèbres dans la bande dessinée on
développe entre deux univers totalement
différent il faut aujourd'hui oeuvre
commune ça s'appelle apocalypse et 7 et
c'est à la galerie barbier à paris
jusqu'au 28 mars
cette berline le leader du groupe ita qu
il sera en concert le 5 mars à
l'institut du monde arabe dans le cadre
d' arabes au folie's l'artiste
plasticienne pilar albarracin qui expose
à la galerie vallois ça s'intitule
n'éteint pas le feu laisse-moi brûlé et
le comédien valentin de carbonnières
molière de la révélation masculine
l'année dernière qui joue transmission
une pièce de ville c'est davis qui a
fait le tour du monde au théâtre
hébertot
mais d'abord notre époque qu'est ce qui
la caractérise voici vos réponses en
images on commence par la vôtre philippe
druillet une charpente
ah oui ça vous ressemble bien je sais
c'est ça vient pour moi de la phrase
d'un peu mémère que tu aimes des
fondateurs de cette merveille qui
s'appelle la bombe atomique et qui a
parlé de notre société qui a dit de
laisser faire de toute façon elle périra
par sa propre technologie
nous sommes tous devenus fous et nous
avons cette espèce de caumont dire de
morbach accroché dans un endroit intime
et qui empêche tout regard et toute
discussion avec qui que ce soit d'une
manière humaine j'entends qui mit en
moins est devenu une partie de notre
corps est à moi qui suivent tiré de la
science fiction je dois dire que j'ai
une haine redoutable et une passion
parce que dès que je le perds je deviens
fou et j'ai passé ma vie à détruire des
transistors qui ne marchaient pas parce
que je suis petit peu nerveux et dans le
privé je suis entre le capitaine haddock
est comment dire notre lit pétition
jacques palmer et c'est le seul objet
que je ne peux pas étrangler et ça ça
m'énerve profondément et voir dans des
trains dans des tgv des gens dans les
salles de dans les pièces de deux de
quatre sièges
ne se regarde pas qui ne se parlent pas
et qu'ils ne font que ça toute la
journée
c'est épouvantable faut c'est terrifiant
et néanmoins c'est une invention
absolument incroyable quoi donc voilà
françois avril et choisi l'image à peu
près inverse 5 au bout
oui voilà regarder non ben forcément
quand on m'a demandé de mettre de donner
une image qui représente notre époque at
y en a plein et c'est surtout pas celle
là
bien sûr que non c'est m sont toutes
tellement consternante et qu elle
m'énerve que je me suis dit je vais je
vais faire le ronchon je vais m'énerver
contre la planète entière encore que ce
soit paris que j'aime pourtant mais
qu'est devenu un pari que je n'ai plus
du tout le bruit qui m'agresse les nous
ont parlé des téléphones de tous les
écrans de tout ça enfin bref
l'impression que comme je vieillis en
fait tout tout m'a agacé je deviens ce
serait une sorte de terre promise mais
je la connais en plus parce que ça c'est
là vu que j'ai de ma maison en bretagne
donc voila j'aimerais que le monde
ressemble à ça avec ce local s'est très
bien débrouillé bien tu parleras d'un
album de la même manière si tu
exactement passage vous arrange mais
mais bon au vu de votre image à vous
c'est du tiki tiki kiki picasso tout à
fait série chinoise de kiki donc quand
on dit aussi qu'on a utilisé comme
couverture pour le deuxième album d'un
artiste republic of the calm et projet
et qui s'appelle l'album s'appelle une
halte et de dictature vieille europe
d'où le symbole européen donc pour moi
ça représente bien
enfin une des facettes de notre société
puisqu'on à la société du spectacle en
bas avec les gens qui sont en train de
regarder leur écran et qui se régalent
de ce qu'on leur montre à la télévision
dans les médias donc savoir tout y
compris la souffrance d'autrui et alla
donc j'ai trouvé que ça sera présenté
bien l'époque un peu voyeuriste et
pornographique dans laquelle on vit avec
rue el pilar albarracin voilà c'est bien
elle c'est l'amérique du sud mais vu de
cette élite têtus les tulles et c'est
fodé les saints dernier de l'an dernière
et pour moi ça époque c'est un époque et
qui met faire et flexi sur les futurs de
notre planète et la forêt c'est d'aider
les hommes de la famille d'el devenir l
on voit d'ailleurs de la zone totalement
noir c'est là c'est la base unis là où
il n'y a pas de lumière du tout c'est la
mélodie lama sony wii l'an dernier c'est
ctu et valentin des corbières de
carbonnières de cars venus a pas de
vains mots est alors c'est sûr qu'elle
revient parce qu'ils sont cons en a
parlé il ya pas très longtemps dans
cette édition justement
mais ça c'est encore une autre c'est une
rivière c'est un lac c'est un set en
deux séances et sixième continent
ah oui c'est lui ouais c'est à dire ce
continent qui a émergé qui fait
plastiques jeux en réfléchissant un peu
à cet endroit enfin cette chose que vous
lui demandez sur l'image qui représente
notre époque
je trouve ça trop difficile de trouver
une image qui représente notre époque et
de ça et malheureusement j'ai pris celle
là mais je trouve ça la regarde bien
ouais mais croise et ses terribles etc
et puis ça fait un peu donneur de leçons
et moi je ne suis pas donneur de leçons
mais hier soir vous devez choisir
l'animal je suis sorti du théâtre et
j'ai vu une poubelle qui dégueulait de
plastique et ce plastique étaient
emmenés par le vent dans les rues de
paris
et ben voilà il faut que je prenne un
truc avec le plastique 6ème continent
machin etc
c'est comme ça on est des décharges à
ciel ouvert c'est très difficile de
revenir en arrière même limite trop
difficile encore là dernièrement à un
spectateur qui m'a dit ah bravo etc
on a discuté ensemble et je dis qu'est
ce que vous faites dans la ville du jeu
je suis dans une entreprise de sacs
plastiques
ça existe encore m'a dit oui et ça
marche du feu de dieu
donc c'est très difficile de revenir en
arrière en fait là cependant et surtout
ce que je trouve très intéressant c'est
ces quatre personnes dans le bateau là
ouais
elles ont l'air très très seul c'est à
dire que j'ai la sensation aussi que
cette ce continent de plastique qui nous
rend seul on ne sait pas quoi faire on
ne sait pas comment revenir en arrière
et quand on se retourne vers à vernon
compatriote nos voisins ils nous disent
aussi je sais pas on sait pas quoi faire
il ya eric loizeau un navigateur qui
était là il ya deux jours et qui lui
disait qu en fait tous plastique on peut
en faire de l'énergie
ben oui mais il ya déjà des machines car
ils n'arrêtent pas de dire ça mais
pourtant la production est énorme
aujourd'hui le plastique est bien
commençons
[Musique]
alors fait les berruyers et françois
avril il faut que je vous présente
d'abord chacun à l'état pur philippe
druillet on vous doit d oeuvre
titanesque comme lone sloane dont on
voit la couverture ici voilà votre
dessin qui a bouleversé des générations
de jeunes lecteurs de bandes dessinées
dont j'ai fait partie mais aussi la nuit
plus récents voilà voilà ce qu'est le
dessin de philippe douillet très dense
plein de fureur et puis françois avril
c'est à tout autre univers suffit de
voir votre art book par exemple voilà on
est dans quelque chose c'est la ligne
claire c'est on va voir aussi si side et
là on comprend que voilà que vous êtes
très différents et pourtant que
peut-être à cause de cela vous avez fait
oeuvre commune
ça s'appelle apocalypse c'est à la
galerie barbier jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin
du mois de mars je crois c'est également
un livre édité à 500 exemplaires
alors on dirait que ce mariage du plein
et du vide qui donne des oeuvres qu'on
va voir s'afficher à partir de
maintenant qui en a eu l'idée
jean françois avril voilà un délateur
c'est lui alors les oeuvres qu'on voit
sur les autres qui sont exposés qui
figure dans le livre et que vous avez
fait ensemble à ilya et du avril et du
12 juillet dans des proportions
différentes selon les desseins alors
elle cette idée saugrenue en apparence
sas au grenier celmo mais bon c'est moi
l'instigateur mais à partir d'une image
en fait de philippe c'est à dire que
j'avais acheté il ya une vingtaine
d'années un dessin de philippe dans une
galerie d'ailleurs la même galerie et il
avait toujours ornée
les murs de mon appartement mais quand
je l'avais acheté forcément j'avais vu
quelque chose qui entrait en résonance
avec avec mon propre univers
c'est un dessin moins dense moins
remplie avec des côtes comme ça et des
têtes qui émergent et des côtes
c'était une esquisse pour un décor
d'excalibur ou quelque chose comme ça
d'un dessin animé et 1 et donc que j'ai
toujours eu ce dessin mais ni plus je
l'avais plus je le regardais plus je
voyais ce qu'il y avait un peu de moi
dans ce dessein style peu prétentieux et
donc un jour j'en avais parlé à philippe
de ça et trouve ça un peu bizarre il me
regardait d'un air bizarre un peu
étrange interrogateurs plus et je lui
dis ça serait amusant qu'on fasse
quelque chose ensemble et c'est avec
deux univers par un très différents même
aux antipodes
je pense que je sais pas il fallait une
sacrée dose de culot ce qui nous relie
vraiment ce qu'est ce qui est très beau
c'est de mélanger les contraire et ça
peut être un ratage nous en avons parlé
souvent on pouvait aller aussi au
massacre
le jeu était dangereux mais surtout il
est très rare à paris
malika warhol deux artistes qui sera
qu'à un moment on est heureux je joue
bien dans leur peau du visage dans les
arts plastiques plus tôt par la
correspondance par la kalachnikov
nous on essaye de passer par autre chose
mais ce point commun entre françois et
moi c'est la notion de l'espace
justement par des lois parce qu'il ya
celui ci que je trouve très intrigant
cette oeuvre là ce que je me suis dit
l'aïe qui commence qui a commencé sur
cette oeuvre la plus particulièrement ce
que les deux espaces sont comment vous
les est réparé c'est très simple c'est
très simple et très compliqué donc je
vais essayer d'être clair ce qui est
absolument impossible
c'est lui qui commençait une amie des
grands formats travail sur ventes est
conforme à 6 les 80 120 à peu près voix
- ou plus selon vous choisissez vous
même très bien
et il était le metteur en scène il avait
dessiné au crayon d'une classe entre les
joueurs les emplacements
oui la mise en place la mise en place tu
vas te mettre là tu vas te battre l'as
tu vas te mettre là et moi étant
totalement fasciné par l'idée d'aborder
d'une parce qu'il y avait cette espèce
d'osmose parce que si deux artistes
travaillent ensemble c'est quand même
qu'ils ont quelque chose qui s'appelle
l' amitié et respect mutuel de leur
propre travail
ok j'aurais pas travailler certains mais
je ne dirais pas les nous surtout la
menace bien entendu mais voilà ça après
des émissions en bref donc je vais dire
que quand ils vous donnent ça vous
décidez pas se voir les défunts à lui
non non non ce qui sait ce crayon est
mise en place
et ce qui est fabuleux c'est que j'ai
trouvé à chaque fois ma place et
l'harmonie et j'ai deviné c'est assez
fou ce qu'il allait faire
derrière donc il ya eu une espèce une
sorte de mélange subtil de communion
vraiment une communion de travail et
c'est une exposition j'en ai fait des
paquets des expos des thèmes et celle ci
m'a particulièrement touché parce
qu'elle avait quelque chose de profond
et à une notion de désert là dedans
est-ce que c'est l'apocalypse aussi et
c'est un désert où tout d'un coup il ya
une renaissance
eyal peut-être une trace de civilisation
disparue chez sprint héros parce que
comment aussi dont on va rester sur
celle-là je voulais avoir la vie de
françois avril je vous redonne la parole
juste devant boy
oui maintenant là par exemple vous ne
l'aviez laissé le centre mais vous
saviez ce qu'il allait faire parce que
tous les deux dans des échelles
totalement différente d'ailleurs quand
on voit vos albums en général vous êtes
dans des échelles différentes les dans
le gigantisme mais vous au contraire
vous êtes beaucoup plus dans le ja côté
microscopique panne que tu touches que
des grands tableaux même des tableaux
énorme en fait beaucoup plus grand que
lui mais au fait c'est beaucoup plus
calme
c'est plus qu'un mais non là je lui
avais donné donc un format et
j'imaginais quelque chose qui serait sur
les toits mais comme une enseigne avait
même je crois j'avais fait un cadre
comme si c'était une enseigne lumineuse
au dessus des toits
et puis il a pris un tel espace que
quand j'ai vu ça devant j'étais très
étonné et parce qu'on cherchait à ses
pattes et en fait mutuellement et et je
me suis dit veut d'accord mais il avait
pris beaucoup de place donc j'ai rajouté
du v2 en fait de morceaux
j'en ai fait un triptyque pour pouvoir
un peux m'exprimer mais dont alors on
peut passer sur les autres imada mais ça
a changé c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
je lui faisais une proposition et il est
il voyait bien ce qu'il a ce qu'ils
devaient peut-être faire mais il n'en
fait qu'à sa tête et c'est ça qui était
bien et moins après je réagissais
ensuite et je récupère l oeuvre pour la
terminer ceci étant dans certaines
parties parfois on le voit d'ailleurs
ici il ya tant de la domination générale
n'ont pas l'expression général plutôt un
peu de bruit en retrait il très bien
posé là où a décidé françois de le poser
et je trouve ça absolument magnifique
parce qu'on n'est pas là pour se dévorer
mais là pour communier il c'est génial
et il ya cette notion d' espaces de mer
et de désert qui fait qu' il ya une
sorte de renaissance des choses évoluent
et que razer ce qui est intéressant
c'est que vous évoluez aussi dans des
lieux différents
vie libre houllier c'est plutôt des
paysages
futuriste vous êtes souvent dans les
villes et dans les villes d'aujourd'hui
françois un agent de thèmes mot à dire
de prédilection c'est sont les villes où
ils les espaces un peu mais aussi
beaucoup des paysages oui oui c'est vrai
mais j'ai pas quand je pense à vous je
pense toujours à des décors urbains mais
ça a été ça parce que c'était mon
environnement je suis je vais à paris
c'est m voilà j'ai connu ça j'avais du
mal avec tout ce qui était en mouvement
les arbres la mer tout ce qui est tout
ce qui était très structuré avec des
ombres portées franche je comprenais
bien mais après j'ai fait beaucoup de
paysages je pense que je mais c'est
quand même des paysans pour l'un comme
pour l'autre belle et sur le territoire
de l'eau à ben oui bien sûr si jean
genet le jeu c'est la découverte parce
que la notion artistique je crois que
peut être partagé ici par tous chacun
dans son domaine c'est la mise en danger
c'est le dépassement et c'est la volonté
deux d'aller plus loin
on n'est pas artiste pour être payer
tous les mois où il ya deux plombiers je
n'ai rien contre les plombiers
j'entends bien il ya un engagement qui
fait qu'on a pas le droit à l'échec et
d'échecs ça nous arrive à tous forcément
mail à aller vers quelque chose de fort
et d'être là mais moi personnellement
c'est une chose qui m'a énormément
touché et c'est une exposition non je
suis très très fier mais c'est drôle
comme les musiciens ont l'habitude de ce
délai la rencontre d'univers différents
vous allez le faire d'ailleurs avec avec
hakim hamadouche on va en parler tout à
l'heure mais c'est le jeu d'assez
coutumier chez les musiciens d'aller
chercher longtemps pensé à ça justement
c'est vrai que c'est continuer mais
c'est le danger reste présent plutôt que
souvent tout le monde est super prix
donc nous ces gens ont fait trois
répétitions bamba mal et ça marche tout
de suite comme on le sait pas le cas et
parole des gens qui font de la musique
très différente de la vôtre alors que
dallas arts plastiques
c'est très très rare et drôle d'ailleurs
que personne n'ait eu cette tentation
c'est surtout avec philippe aller
se frotter à son univers personnes en
fait mes talents d'artistes comédiens
il m'a coupé j'ajoute regagné 3 secondes
au suivant olivier métal n'avait pas des
rencontres comme ça entre les défunts
dans des rencontres contre les îles en
métal hurlant métal hurlant partageons
métal hurlant talent hurlant oui on a
que jean pierre dionnet médius et moi
même avons créé il y avait des
rencontres comme ça mais c'est vrai que
c'est rare dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est très curieux
je suis sûr que ça existait mais il ya
peu de traces on en a pas vraiment mais
moi je pense un mélange entre van dijk
et picasso vous imaginez un peu le
collage que ça peut-être là ce n'est pas
un cadavre exquis
ce sont les surréalistes ce n'est pas
vrai d'ailleurs qui ont inventé le
cadavre exquis
mais on cache un morceau du dessin et le
dessinateur ensuite continue là nous
étions en osmose on voyait et il
m'amenait délice pour moi gros feignants
malgré mon travail d' hystérique de voir
que je savais où me mettre et me laisser
libre et retrouver une chose capitale
pour tout artiste son âme d'enfant
le plaisir le bonheur de faire ça c'est
quelque chose d'inouï c'est la chose la
plus belle du monde
pouvoir vivre de son art je ne suis pas
milliardaire
mais vivre de son art de son travail de
son oeuvre pas être prétentieux de son
travail
c'est quelque chose d'unique justement
puisqu'on parle d'argent
toutes ces oeuvres sont à vendre vous
répartissez l'argent équitablement
grosses bagnoles
non bien sûr que ça peut être à celui
qui aime plus décidé non non je ne sais
pas
tout à fait partagé est alors une oeuvre
comme celle ci par exemple elle fait
quelle taille pascal bassi c'est une des
moins grande
je dirais qu'elle est elle est comme ça
seulement c'est la grosse tête faisait
un mètre soixante dix de long ou en tout
cas n'avait donc vous voyez ce sont de
tailles très différentes
un moment donné la galerie nous a dit ne
fait pas que des oeuvres monumentales
pour des russes voilà tout dur à londres
voilà donc qui s'est aguerri barbier
d'ailleurs qui est au 10 rue choron et
ses ruches aux roues qui était le siège
d'hara kiri c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
que georges bernier a pris comme
pseudonyme le professeur je suis revenu
en hommage à la ruche auront qui en fait
selon l'onda compositeur mais c'était
juste après vous étiez pas dans la bande
de dahra j'étais très très très ami avec
georges wolinski et jean jean cabu et
beaucoup d'autres aussi mais gb tout ça
et c'était des êtres que j'aimais
beaucoup et l'horreur n'est pas passée
il ne passera jamais c'est la chose de
clair donc voilà un merci sont pas la
soirée françois avril
vous êtes la génération qui a lui qui a
découvert de rouiller dans pilote à la
fin des années 60 tout au début des
années 70 oui j'aimais pas trop vous
aviez patron c'était pour aller non
c'est à dire que du moins ça m'a
impressionné je comprenais pas trop ça
faisait l'éloge oui c'était parce qu'ils
lisent ils des grands comme ça moi je
cherchais effectivement être beaucoup
plus minima le trait à synthétiser et
puis au fil du temps je suis rentré dans
son univers j'ai rendu compte de la
richesse de la densité de ce monde
puis on prend ces rencontres et on est
devenus amis et puis et c'est ça c'est
ça les rencontres et surtout on ont tous
les gens qui ont commencé à parler un
petit peu du projet personne n'y croyait
en fait se dit c'est pas possible vous 2
c'est pas possible et surtout
professionnel oui et quand on leur
montrait et qui voyait les premières
visées
ok d'accord c'est ça qui est kim
estimant parce que tout à l'heure vous
parliez de basquiat et
et oui moi j'ai pensé à ça parce que je
me suis dit c'est il avait fait quelque
chose ensemble mais ça faisait des
oeuvres pertinentes et c'était vraiment
le souci qu'on avait en fait voilà
c'était que ce soit pas une plaisanterie
que ça fasse quelque chose d'harmonieux
des chose de pertinent pas des voix là
est bien faite à la galerie barbier dix
ruches auront jusqu'au 28 mars
[Musique]
ces ballerines vous êtes auteur
compositeur interprète producteur
vous êtes le leader du groupe ithaque et
d'anarchistes republic of bees
vous parliez tout à l'heure mais je
propose pour qu'on fasse connaissance
on va regarder un extrait de votre clip
réalisé avec ithaque cette fois ci ça
s'appelle le jeu flight basten univers
là aussi on va voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais seuls ceux des rames
je sens quand
le spasme
l'hiver
[Musique]
je vais couvre absence
gilles a
[Musique]
et
philippe doyer ça vous aura amusé de
travailler sur des ordinateurs comme ça
je vous voyais captivé travailler
désormais oui je sais mais je n'ai
aveyron je ne venais pas la technique
mais je sais ce que je veux et c'est
bien parce que y'a tout ce qu'on vient
de dire avant et à cette forme de
terreur qui nous est cette forme de
beauté absolue et et en plus ça arrache
un petit peu c'est bien ce groupe vous
l'avait appelée black c'est l'acronyme
de quoi ithaque parce que c' it et h
ak waimes ces instituts techno
harmonique de cordage cosmique
voilà c'est ça le bruit des marques de
voiture à l'origine c'est sensé ça
serait faire un peu je me suis cassé
gurdjieff cet arménien justement qui
s'était quelque peu galéré perdu un oeil
ouais du coup qui est l'institut pour le
développement de l'homme je crois et
puis bon 1 1 puis bon cd du lys
évidemment et et vous vouliez faire sans
musique de non je dirais que le nom
enfin pour être tout à fait franc les
initiales ont donné le nom après quoi
c'est d'abord de l'estrie drôle c'est
que vous êtes passé par l'ircam
ouais et alors normalement l'ircam on se
dit c'est pierre boulez c'est la musique
atonale je suis même passé par une école
d'ingénieurs donc oui je reviendrai en
fait derrière kabylie besoin puis quoi
l'ircam déjà bon à l'époque avait pas
internet un document à l'ircam sam a
déjà ouvert les oreilles sur tout ce qui
était une musique contemporaine ligety
xenakis griset et compagnie donc tous
les jours j'étais à la bibliothèque de
l'ircam à écouter à écouter du son
c'était une des plus grosses
bibliothèques vie contemporaine de
france je pense à et ils m'ont appris
après moi je travaillais sur un champ
louis chaix appelé modalis donc synthèse
par analyse modèle c'est un truc assez
pointu aura pas rentrer dans les détails
mais voilà donc c'était une façon pour
moi de de clôture et ma carrière
inexistence d'ingénieurs et de
d'enchaîner sur une carrière musicale en
fait et j'ai commencé par le rap je
crois alors ça je le faisais déjà
pendant mes études avant en maths sup
maths spé j'avais déjà un groupe de rap
est un groupe de hardcore en fait dans
qu'est ce que le temps pour bosser les
mains il fait un mariage des personnes
ont fait une pause et on retrouve tout
de suite c'est benzin
et la suite de sa carrière pour en
arriver jusqu à l'institut du monde
arabe et de prochain concert qui aura
lieu
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant est ce
qu'on peut faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays vieux 500 c'est là
où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
passe
et ça me parler de fracture entre le
nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
vous avez deux pays de la zone euro et
donc les pays du sud qui n'ont pas
encore retrouvé leur niveau de richesse
d'avant la crise vous avez la grèce et
aussi lit-on malgré tout les aides qu'on
a pu avoir au niveau de la zone euro n'a
pas réussi à sortir de la crise
c'est à dire qu'on vous parle de la
baisse du chômage au portugal ou en
espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que tous ces pays die notamment chez
nous en france des publics a augmenté
mais n'a pas généré 350 je ne sais pas
qui est la locomotive de l'europe en
tout cas ne croyez pas que ce soit la
france
[Musique]
les invités sont aujourd'hui philippe
druillet françois avril pour apocalypse
à la galerie barbier pilar albarracin
dont l'exposition à la galerie vallois
s'intitule n'éteint pas le feu
laisse-moi brûlé valentin de
carbonnières qui joue transmission avec
francis huster au théâtre hébertot et
ses belles piscines qui sera donc en
concert le 5 mars à l'institut du monde
arabe dans le cadre d' arabes au folie's
acte iv vous avez été également
influencé par la musique ottomane
j'ai l'impression ouais ben j'ai vécu en
fait je vécu cinq ans à istanbul
mais pour d pour des raisons privées
pour nos personnels et donc
effectivement je suis tombé amoureux de
cette musique cette culture de manière
générale donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé
cette musique là et donc j'ai intégré
sans même le vouloir consciemment mais
c'est intégré d'elle-même dans dans mon
vocabulaire musical donc hop hip hop
hardcore musique contemporaine plus chez
musique music ottomane ça peut donner on
va regarder un extrait de principe
l'offre en action alors ça c'est un
album solo vous avez sorti il ya un ou
deux ans vous regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce
j'ai l'impression quand on vous écoute
que vous avez fait la fusion de toutes
les musiques arabes et occidentales au
fond qui cumule par couche comme ça sort
pas cette prétention là mais c'est une
fusion par amis aussi justement il ya
une couche qui va se rajouter donc au
cours de ce concert du 5 mars puisque
vous allez jouer avec hakim hamadouche
qui joue du monde aux luttes électrique
qui accompagnèrent à cheetah pendant 25
ans à peu près alors là c'est encore une
autre couche c'est le chaabi que vous
rajoutez chaabi tous afin que pour coup
je connaissais très peu en fait j'ai
rencontré rachid sur la fin de sa vie
son nez date est censé travailler
ensemble et donc on compterait hakim par
ricochet on s'est tout de suite bien
entendu parce que lui aussi vient il a
toujours bol mélanger beaucoup de
musiques différentes touches abîmées
aussi avec le jazz ou le même le rock le
punk tout ça j'ai apprécié que le style
de notre époque musicalement c'est la
fusion en fait on n'a pas inventé de
nouvelles musiques depuis à peu près 25
ans donc on fusionne tout ce qui existe
en fait je crois que toutes les musiques
sont tout le temps des fusions d'autres
choses de cette façon c'est ça se fait
par ces comme l'être humain on évolue
par des adn qui se mélangent fin n'y a
pas de ya pas de nouvel être humain qui
apparaît d'un coup et c'est pareil je
cours pour la création artistique fin je
sais pas pour vous mais moi
personnellement je suis influencé par
10000 les artistes est nourri par ça et
c'est comme ça que sa nouvelle chose se
crée et à quoi ça va ressembler alors ce
concert que beaucoup de monde attend
puisque la rencontre des deux
personnalités
laird excitez pas mal de monde ça va
être génial un peu comme la rencontre de
philippe druillet et veut françois avril
ouais bah ça va être surprenant je pense
on n'y a pas d'image ya pas de son nom
mais tout va être créé non mais
je suis premiers curieux de savoir quand
c'est comme ça alors en attendant pour
la route d'un couteau je crois que c'est
votre dernier clip c'est el mektoub avec
mister k bine dernière extraits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas à nous pour nous
la mauritanie filiales
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
le côté amusant
totalement
kiffer
il ya comme un fait
[Musique]
2 manon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
ces berlines donc en concert pavec
ithaque mais avec hakim hamadouche à
l'institut du monde arabe le 5 mars dans
le cadre du festival arabe au folie's
[Musique]
pilar albarracin vous vous exposez la
galerie vallois c'est rue de seine à
paris je vais vous laisser prononcer le
nom de l'exposition en espagnol comment
vous dites
ce qui veut dire des tapas feu
laisse-moi bollée alors pour comprendre
votre travail et il faut savoir que vous
êtes et a sévi et que vous revisitez
l'identité andalouse de manière assez
critique
par exemple sur le flamenco ça donne des
oeuvres comme celle ci et ou alors sur
la tauromachie
ça a donné ça voilà alors qu'est-ce que
vous critiquez exactement qu'est ce qui
vous déplaît dans l'identité andalouse
r je pense qu est plus que critique et
j'ai fait j'aimais faire réfléchir à mm
il espère que comme on travaille les
person il peut réfléchir aussi sur la
vie les clichés l'hérault de la femme y
notera situation allait monde
alors cette nouvelle exposition elle est
plutôt consacré à la semaine sainte qui
se déroule chaque année à séville au
mois d'avril je crois alors ça donne des
images comme celles ci que l'on va voir
alors on vous y voit brûler et et vous
tenez dans les mains ce livre c'est quoi
ce livre sa livre c'est un livre sera
les cinq années est de l'espagne avec
franck
oui après free et et et pourquoi vous
faites vous brûlez qu'est ce qui se
passe pendant cette semaine sainte que
nous on ignore mais qui est si
importante pour les pour les andalous et
je travaille avec
il suce que centre et espagnole mais ils
sont mettra potable et à du lemon way
unsa location j'ai travaillé sur les
faux comment un élément qui peut faire
changer les choses n'est pas la
destruction mais c'est là on passe à la
nouvelle vie mais également des oeuvres
qui représente alors ça s'appelle lou
sait s'ils sont brasse ça veut dire quoi
la lumière et ombre s'est pas oui c'est
une série de l'image comme celle ci on
va en voir quelques unes
c'est à chaque fois votre main j'imagine
et mon mari les mandé maintenance
assistance d'accord et qui tiennent des
cierges alors là aussi qu'est ce que ça
signifie une chose qu'un peu
significatif et rance
douar différents significant non je
n'avais pas dire unique à moment
signifie qu'en sinon je coupe des
possibilités d qu'est ce que cette
particulier cette semaine sainte à
séville
j'ai parlé ici des la semana santa mais
je parlais des
la pénitence l'aïd et de la pénitence et
aussi la lie d'aider la combi nations
avec la lumière
il est sombre sans lumière n'hésitez pas
les sombres sans ombre pas de lumière à
lumière il ya également vos broderie qui
sont exposés l'appareil
en ce qui me concerne je ne sais pas à
quoi cela fait référence mais c'est très
joli ces mystérieux mr si ces mystérieux
et tellement je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
y à a nécessité à des contraintes et eu
et il y un parent d la vie que tu ne
peux comprendre ça vous inspire quoi
les boyer c'est symbolique et du
symbolisme et de gaieté risme donc voilà
je crois avoir compris une partie des
choses dit par défiance et a pu alors y
aider parce que vous êtes vidéaste aussi
ayez des petits films tout à fait dedans
on va regarder deux ils sont très très
court et ben y'a rien à en dire si ce
n'est que ça s'appelle la bête la banque
le monstre lavette la bête il gèle effet
avec un copain et artix aussi qu'elle
fait la musique
autre chose c'est assez étonnant on
regarde le premier
[Musique]
sa devise est d'aider des idées de clip
s m l usine
ça s'est fait avec on sait pas quoi
c'est fait avec rien réglé réveille avec
différents sur ce qui est du sens et de
la boîte noire alors un autre toujours
la bête
[Musique]
françois weill non je regardais ça je le
disais en même temps qu'il y avait du
film brouillée non non oui très simple
est une couleur fabuleuse mais le noir
et le blanc n'existe pas dans la nature
le noir pur n'existe pas c'est l'homme
qui l'a inventé et le blanc pur n'existe
pas dans la nature
c'est un mélange de couleurs et nous
l'avons inventé les scientifiques les
par les chimistes ont fait un blanc pur
un plan doit il n'ya pas c'est des
couleurs qui n'existe pas dans la langue
de seiche ou de pioche est pas noir se
demander ce que je me dis c'est le
cinéma qui les a popularisé on peut dire
le noir et blanc
valentin commentaire il ya peu d'acteurs
bon quand même
c'est bien comme ça si on voit une forme
avant une forme humaine mais ouais ça me
donne moi en fait là là le fait que ça
s'appelle la bête et qu'on voit les
cheveux comme ça je pense tout de suite
à la belle et la bête en noir et blanc
avec les le costume qui avait jean
marais mais aussi
ça me fait penser aussi à des travaux
d'artistes contemporains que j'ai vu et
je trouve ça très très organique hyper
intéressant je trouve ça très proche du
du cauchemar et du rêve c'est moi je
trouve ça hyper chouette ça vient
surtout si une chose qui est très
ancienne ça s'appelle l'ombre chinoise
il découpage tout à fait qu'on anime
aujourd'hui éliminé à technologiques
modernes mais c'est de l'ombre chinoise
est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
mystère c'est le mystère et là on peut
tout vous projetez d'ailleurs très
mystérieux pilar albarracin vous avez
l'intention de vous attaquer à d'autres
identités d'autres cultures que la vôtre
que la culture andalouse
un jour oui à bout à la fin je pense que
on était plus proche des les autres
sculptures hockey qu'elle nous pensons
si elle travaille beaucoup avec mon
culture mais les choses importantes et
sont la même pour tous ont changé
appelle à la patience
mais les fondamental c'est c'est
universel c'est donc à la galerie
vallois 33 36 rue de seine à paris et
c'est jusqu'à mais je sais plus jusqu'à
qu'on met en scène jusqu'au 11 mars à
sainte on se lave rien 11 avril au moins
assuré
[Musique]
valentin de carbonnières je le disais au
début de cette émission vous avez reçu
le molière 2010 9 de la révélation
masculine au théâtre donc est ce que ça
a changé votre vie ben ça a permis de
dire non ouais bah les trucs avant je
disais s'il vous plaît qui un peu plus
non mais aussi ça m'a ça m'a mis plus de
pression parce que les gens du coup
attendre plus de
de l'homme qui a huit qui a été primée
quoi et puis voilà ça va augmenter vos
cachets le cesa finalement ça augmente à
cacher a commenté cachait pas d'argent
c'est bien donc
vous avez dit oui à transmission que
vous jouez au théâtre hébertot en duo
avec francis juste heurte une bien
caisse de bill 6,6 davis a rencontré un
énorme succès international comment vous
l'expliquez bas parce que au-delà de
parler d'un univers d'un univers
religieux ça parle d'une rencontre et
d'humanité c'est quelque chose qui est
toujours présent qui est toujours
actuelle c'est-à-dire la rencontre entre
deux générations celle qui arrive est
celle qui part resté deux prêtres en
l'occurrence un vieux prêtre irlandais
appellent colo joué par par francis
huster et vous vous êtes le ses
vis-à-vis séminaristes voilà voilà
et ça les américains beaucoup soldes que
des français s'ils sont miss et le sait
le côté du elle nourrit du home et
sociales duel ces deux personnages comme
ça qui s'affrontent
ça a donné aussi bien en france le
souper de jean goyer valence ville avec
fouché et talleyrand
il ya eu la pièce aussi avec fürtwangler
face à son accusateur américain après
des arrêts à raison après la seconde
guerre mondiale etc etc c'est comment à
jouer ça c'est comment on pense avec
match de tennis avec un ipad c'est ça
c'est ça ouais c'est vachement ça m'a
d'ailleurs hier soir francis était très
en forme et moi j'avais j'avais une
grosse journée est clairement j'ai perdu
un set c'est très agréable ce qui est
très agréable ceci de remettre le
travail sur l'établi tous les soirs
comme disait l'autre boileau là c'est à
dire d'arriver et qui se passe quelque
chose tous les soirs entre nous pas
entre les deux acteurs pas trop entre
les deux personnages mais aussi entre
nous francis est quelqu'un que moi je ne
connaissais pas qui représentait pour
moi une
quelque chose d'historique presque c'est
quand même un homme qui a 72 ans qui a
travaillé avec énormément de gens qui a
fait énormément de rôle et qui a fait un
duo avec alain delon d'ailleurs
variations énigmatiques alors le cdfa
l'américaine n'était pas le côté belge
de tennis mais c'est normal avait déjà
fait un face à face c'est une rencontre
quoi ouais donc donc voilà il a joué
deux jeunes et est aussi moi je viens je
viens quand même du théâtre subventionné
d'un de d'un endroit un peu de recherche
etc
et quand j'ai entendu parler de francis
huster pour moi il y avait beaucoup de
préjugés
il y avait beaucoup de choses et puis on
m'a dit beaucoup de choses aussi
on a su que j'avais travaillé avec mon
système a dit voilà l'action machin etc
et quand j'ai rencontré le mec bas c'est
toujours la même chose c'est beaucoup
plus évident beaucoup plus simple cet
homme est très professionnel très en
empathie très dans la bienveillance
trait sur le détail
donc du coup c'est génial moi j'ai hâte
d'être ce soir pour me retrouver face à
lui sur le plateau et défendre des trucs
quoi alors bien et se passe c'est que
excusez moi mais ça se passe c'est que
ça représente vraiment ce qu'on est tous
les deux c'est à dire que moi je
j'arrive un peu dans l'univers théâtral
et cetera j'ai envie de défendre des
trucs j'ai envie de défendre une pureté
peut-être voilà et lui représente un peu
le théâtre privé et le théâtre populaire
aussi de populaire et puis il est un
prêtre populaire oui tout à fait et et
et donc du coup ce qui se passe sur
scène c'est aussi de façon de faire du
théâtre aussi là justement on va
regarder la bande annonce alors il faut
imaginer donc ce prêtre populaire cool
moderne sûrement à une époque ce que
c'est ça il est un peu vatican ii on va
dire
et puis face à lui arrive à un jeune
séminariste sur radicale prise exigeant
et en même temps plus complexes
notamment sur le plan sexuel
et voilà voilà la bande annonce
monseigneur burke accepte vous devez
dire à la condition et sous réserve que
je travaille avec vous j'ai aucune envie
travailler avec vous savez vous
deviendrez un média et moi ça prend un
trader
bébé est mort dans son berceau à lui
donne alors vous pouvez dire si la mer
est jeune vous en aurez un autre
[Musique]
didier n'importe quoi à ces batailles
dans le besoin poussé par zoug l'adverbe
[Musique]
c'est pas le problème ce qu'ils pensent
de medouar sg l'irak est où le problème
[Musique]
le christ on est à ses apôtres prêcher à
travers le monde
il les envoya deux par deux je pense que
je comprends vraiment pourquoi alors ce
qui est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
au fond il ya toute l'actualité de du
vatican dans cette pièce je sais pas de
quoi elle date d'ailleurs elle plusieurs
années parce qu'on y parle à la fois du
célibat des prêtres et on se demande
aujourd'hui s'il faudrait pas rompre
avec son célibat
pourtant ancestrale on parle aussi de
l'ordination des femmes
vous savez quand il l'a écrite bill sli
d'avis il a écrite ya pas mal de temps
je sais pas exactement mais en fait elle
a été quand même retraduite et ils ont
travaillé bill ces délices et davy
sardou ensemble pour qu'elle soit un peu
plus contemporaines dont quelques uns il
ya des règles fait sourire voilà
exactement
il ya des choses qui ont changé pour la
rendre encore plus percutante et est du
coup voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'elle
sonne elle sonne bien bien contemporaine
bien d'aujourd'hui
cette ode et socialement quand même
autour du sexe ce qui es tu on est ado
mais en même temps que je crois que
c'est toujours ce qui fascine tout le
monde dans la religion catholique c'est
que les prêtres font voeu de chasteté ça
reste un mystère
il essaye de toucher personne quoi c'est
quand même incroyable ce rapport à ce
rapport à l'autre ce rapport aux à la
peau de l'autre
ce rapport à la tactique ils peuvent
toucher il peut vous serez non mais je
veux dire de vous voir peau de quelque
chose d'autre dans steam quoi c'est
quelque chose quand même incroyable
l'amour de dieu c'est incroyable alors
il ya l'amour de dieu et puis il ya
plein d'autres choses qui rentrent en
parallèle et du coup je c'est pour ça
que ça ça intéresse autant et ça ça rend
curieux les gens évidemment mais il ya
aussi une autre opposition me
semble-t-il c'est entre ce ce prêtre
gentil profondément bon pour moi c'est
vraiment vatican ii c'est à dire que
c'est quand dieu est devenu le bon dieu
le bon dieu qui vous pardonne qui vous
comprend ce pas grave si vous n'allez
pas là mais c'est pas grave si vous
confesser pas d'ailleurs plus personne
ce qu'on fait c'est de moins en moins de
gens vont à la messe
et puis en face il ya l'autre le jeune
qui arrive plus radicale et qui a envie
de revenir à la la religion d'entente
parce que là aussi ça dans
l'ancien testament et le nouveau
testament ya les deux est toujours la
querelle des anciens et des modernes
oui et puis surtout il ya ces deux
choses il ya cette fois qui est
agressive dans la dent l'ascétisme dans
en différence sur deux choses la
possible le célibat le rapport à
l'adultère le rapport aux mensonges
le rapport à l'hypocrisie qui est
terrible aujourd'hui et et en même temps
ce rapport à ce dieu qui est acquis
amour etc
ces deux ambivalence assez incroyable
comme un peu le blanc et noirs et du
coup c'est difficile de prendre parti et
c'est vrai que ces deux personnages
incarnent ces deux grands camps qui vont
qui vont s affronter
et est ce que ça marche les gens qui
viennent sont plutôt des catholiques ou
cette touche ce qui est super chouette
c'est qu'il ya tout ça c'est hyper
agréable parce que quand je disais tout
à l'heure ça ça dépasse complètement le
milieu religieux complètement ça
pourrait être dans n'importe quel milieu
finalement parce que dans n'importe quel
milieu yade il ya des codes et des
interdits il ya des choses et des gens
qui arrivent pour casser les codes pour
reformer les gens qui nous ont formés
quoi philippe douillet quand vous avez
commencé à décider non à dessiner des
récits de science-fiction est ce que
vous imaginiez que la religion
perdurerait s l'époque et en 68 on pense
que ces filles on en parlera plus jamais
d'abord on ne t'a comme l'armée mais
j'ai un sens précis de la religion qui
est différent donc mais en même temps
j'ai le sens du sacré il était à peine
d'être religieux pour avoir le sens du
sacré la ferme notre-dame et
passionnante parce que il ya quelque
chose à construire quelque chose de
magnifique de moderne et dans la
tradition revenir voulait dire que
driller aurait bien redessiner
j'ai d'ailleurs engagé jeu c'est un
projet un projet est bon alors et boire
j'ai fait un projet ya une chose que
détonnant dans la religion catholique
c'est la haine de son propre corps au
19ème siècle il existait un objet on
appelle une spatule en bois de 80 cm qui
permettait aux prêtres de faire glisser
sa chemise dans l'autre chemises sont
que sa main touche son propre sexe à
leur apporter
c'est quelque chose de fou c'est quelque
chose
nous sommes dans la démence la plus
totale eh bien je remercie tous les sacs
d'avoir participé à cette émission
transmission de bill c davis traduite
par davy sardou mise en scène de steve
suissa avec francis huster et valentin
de carbonnières c'est au théâtre
hébertot apocalypse l'exposition des
oeuvres de philippe druillet françois
avril c'est à la galerie barbier dix
ruches auront à paris jusqu'au 28 mars
l'exposition de pilar albarracin
n'éteint pas le feu l'esm a brûlé c'est
à la galerie vallois 33 36 rue de seine
à paris et ses belles chine sera en
concert avec hakim hamadouche et les
musiciens d'ithaca l'institut du monde
arabe lé 5 mars dans le cadre du
festival arabo police qui se tient du 28
février au 8 mars
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez-vous
au prochain numéro
[Musique]
je
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes